ready let's always ladies with aren't
gonna be fair customized ship which is
gonna be amazing
yeah yeah ship and with our old crew
shoot them with you think - um hi yep oh
you know no no no I got it get it that's
fantastic
I'm gonna shoot him turn to the right a
little bit bring me out here ah Jesse
gonna shoot him with the sniper
all right a bit all of our stuff is
broken right now for the red cam Tran
trying to fix stuff hey Marky supposed
to be fixing whatever I'm gonna shoot
him that's all I can't be an engineer
that please good practice this is a
touring Lurky kitchen cuz they're broken
I like to do a job please I'll put you
on to these jobs it may have been my
fine those are you using After Burner
crap I might have been using special
abilities and one faster than Wow Wow
Wow look it we're job is the crew to
compensate for bad captain uh what if
you have a bad crew Jesse how can we
trust you if you just not doing your job
then the man is mine
it's trying to get him but his aim where
they were now again that's fine keep
going keep get them oh did you wanna get
him bro I'm gonna get him Sir and again
he's dealing in the cream sure him down
keep him down the ground oh oh okay
get on tiny straddle keep it with no
don't do that
yeah we're unrepeated alum okay well
we're moving into straddle I guess I'm
gonna shoot him what you'll shoot
himself
I'm gonna kill him he's almost in range
he's almost here
I say 10 or more still you boot get that
one huh Oh God
why did we move into his fryer in range
that's Frary means why - I didn't turn
to the left so we could blast it with a
fire okay don't gosh - good idea
oh god the smoke I'm weird geez at
Channel Kombat character can't we read
down below Kombat character we're gonna
come out of her and man I'd cry get
ready yes sir oh he's hitting us
meetings yeah water now dum-dum your
wires as we know yeah I get that
IQ is less than other people's yeah he
didn't like this we're insulting him oh
good
you're welcome I'm reloading it's okay
because he's smoking here and have a no
barbecue right now
no he ain't and his mother didn't even
show up uh main oh now she'll join yeah
finish him finish him yes abandoning our
post Ravalli right
Omo go collect the loot captain if I
could just get over wait
oh is rithmetic what for this is one
with three AI is good people look at
vengeance one day he's round crying I
don't know have such a dead that's left
bound appreciated oh then get on the
Left cry when I was sure holy freaking
head alright you get off my balls
I'm not Anya I saw the fire I see the
fire this fire this fire being shot at I
know oh no oh goodness oh oh oh goodness
oh no oh boy where our balloon is on
fire holes down not good okay they sit
on their gun I don't know what you want
to get on actually a rabbi everyone can
sit on get on the side gun I'm on the
side guys then jump the side gun as soon
as I can it doesn't turn that far you
going forward you you got it you got
probably head boom boom heart skip do we
can go real good get him get him cry on
it isn't going down yeah yeah yeah I did
it
he's burning us now uh-oh fire
Roth aye yeah this is not ideal main
guns aya and was open okay we're falling
down quick now I'll go glorious blind
fixing things as fast as I can
making them join us Sarah bad we just
cry oh you're welcome
not seamen Kevin oh you seem alright
good okay look it I fixed you gum for
you thanks appreciate okay oh oh well
REM I can't quite this yeah yeah yeah
fire we did it
yes fire to be brought to the light oh
he's going turn a bit more to the right
and he's gay no keep on with the fire
the fire oh you gotta be more commanding
soon get the bar thank you I said oh I
like that that's a good voice that's a
good tone later Jesus I'm not Jones
happening on this ship but I'm not going
to bed alone tonight cuz how lumber is
down we gotta just get one more good
strike and he's gone can't finish him
off with on the side turned aside get
down go down go down down on him down
deeper Kem down uh-huh and I repeat it
just seems like session significant hits
you doing on him is too low and you
bring up the little groups the son said
his gun was really good it is it is cuz
cuz he he keep destroying his balloons
and he can't really do anything it's
rage inducing is what this gun is and
it's gonna be hardship go crazy
excellent and it's the Joe Lister
screaming you gotta hit the balloon cry
yet you gotta hit the bullet mmm oh no
you know
yeah oh my god he put her down with a
good move so he was doing let's play I'm
sorry I thought I could get a bit more
engine damage in blue angel can you put
on that marques right now oh I see
they're on fire I see that I signed one
big star yeah
so each one fix things specific purpose
so marked weapon on the side there
that's the engine the one you have is
the balloon and the other one is the one
when we go to finish them off cuz that's
really overpowered right okay and then
we're just gonna use a spell
we're just gonna make TV angry he
they're gonna be super tired and I want
them just get mad if they're gonna win I
want them to be pissed off when they win
yeah I want them to have a conversation
about how war is hell and in the inner
in the end there are no winners kind of
thing like first row I don't say if they
win I'm pretty sure they're gonna save
it they're the winners so pretty sure
you see three in the window you know
also I can't give us I can't oh yeah
Adam roost today yep
you have a head charge or at stake about
chat bro you just keep going he's
keeping all that shivers so badly pick
it up you coward who dings I'm gonna
work managing this it I can't hit quite
hit oh we can't quite get like two guns
at once going on a ship with this setup
this is totally fine I'm going s one man
and he's man he's going down
marie-claire ISM oh we didn't oh oh oh
I'm turning darlin
he's been solid Oh didn't kill him I'm
on turn to the right captain so we can
get back in wait oh is that it never
mind I blew him up with my mind you just
hold on are you worried
wait we have a psychic yes I do that
your wallet you are you Cleo
I've been waiting to call you for my
free tarot reading you're still on it
we're like a fox TV don't know psychic
cries fill the wisecracking
twelve-year-old Dodger is the sultry
prostitute who has a heart of gold and I
am your fear so we're Firefly and that's
yeah I said we're Firefly oh well we are
the skills butterfly so it's close well
I'll get ready on the spider guy okay
this didn't happen by accident you guys
never I'm not ready I'm gonna be ready
I travel to carry yeah that sniper rifle
has such a narrow range we might want to
replace that sniper with a Gatling gun
because that's kind of also very
accurate we're about to die for the
record no we're not
are you talking crazy you're right
you're the heart of folds on it okay all
right we're proud yeah we'll probably
get me every frog yeah we're going yeah
does he turn just a little bit to the
right just a little bit to the right all
the right things around I am looking
around guy just a little bit to the
right yeah all mist am also mist
I miss [ __ ] man let me take this oh
no no no I get off anyone I guess I got
you don't get anymore
hey you do it roll you're all kind of
back up in town fall yalda he's really
far off trying to like hide out in the
wreckage of an old spaceship I don't
know what color get a memo it I feel
like we should get below I'm not above
them because we can't hit him but he
sure [ __ ] can hit us do you want to
shoot a balloon why are we can work what
yeah yeah I want to shoot him today what
do you want to shoot my my ship hey wait
what we used to be best crew ease used
to be best crew ease I can't I can't top
that
it's literally best we're not the best
anymore cos a rusty tasty delicious and
we one is a rate oh absolutely
good I mean we're five laughter
maybe not yeah well I'll get okay I'll
get I'll put this out with my
flamethrower okay it's dead never mind
okay no no do it do it
I'm running out to put out different
wires hey hey hey my guns Brooke my
hands Brooke
Oh to the left is on fire
never mind oh forget everything I just
said I'm not real person where's my
cover Sam's a loon I know Jenna fixable
yeah we got it we got it
no leeks and carrots now everybody calm
down you're so impatient absol thank you
heart of gold prostitute God you know
that doesn't repair right that's the
buff tool mark mark just a mark just a
mark just honest you don't have any
other thing to use those Falls that we
spent 10 minutes on the customization
screen I'm a gunner I don't get those
options you know I got it
badly hurt Oh got it I'm on it
I think we're overdosing on SAS in this
particular crew I'm accessory butterfly
mm-hmm
we're getting Roy look yeah like I said
Jesse get below um cuz above them we
can't do much
not exactly what I hadn't turn to the
left Kevin turning go out and do that
I'll fix our gonna cry
all right I'm gonna burn em alive oh
we're dead I don't know if she's alive
or dead yet who didn't renew now yep yep
is bad mama looks bad all right okay all
right well well um ain't this a / - yeah
TV will be real strong medics is his son
sue like an expense there's a genius
wait why do we have AI in here oh we
don't we do not I'm in it I'm in it I
saw like a group of four AI and then
they jumped off the ship it was pretty
cool whoa what the shoes got scary on
Cyrus we took over the ship and that's
how we enter every ship I see like all
you seen a little girl red jumper hey he
switched ships what is going on here
dead he's much closer to my reign hello
I'm hitting you now I'm calling air
jamish to sister
is already taking damage that's okay I'm
going to stables guns he's moving away
faster that is a speedy ship fine okay
oh I've got the bullet I got him I got
him I could hear but all that whole I'm
fixing the hole all right we're gonna
hit him with the other one now okay
yeah goes down got dad cougar I'm gonna
fix you got it got it
I wanna hit him again yeah
hey should we burn him alive oh you
[ __ ]
bounnam burn to the ground burn it all
you can't the barbecue right welcome
above do you like barbecue sauce
barbecue sauce okay yeah I don't think
fan I come back happy
I don't know what that means no that's a
reference to something but I can't
remember what it is it's it we were well
what the hell's that we were just
talking about it uh Billy Madison oh
yeah that's why yeah what he's like have
some more sloppy joes they're like who
are you did nothing to do with the
barbecue but I just wanted to say that
you like it sloppy joes are amazing for
the record don't just mean like sloppy
joes yes
what whoa what whoa whoa
you really are a hard as positive thing
but but here's here's a heart of sad-ass
okay here's what the note also on my
toes I don't like for there be any
juices coming out like I don't like I
don't like burgers like burgers that get
[ __ ] all over the edge so Oh
oh my god you're the worst person -
you're just so good - yes I know
like eating burgers in my process Oh
turn more to the right I guess dirty at
the at the table no dirty and the bed is
fine so classic use across reduces all
that stuff is all okay right mm-hmm
that's why I'm that way he's dying his
holes down yay
a bizarre such her so here I have a
quick question for you develop er um are
you better than to be or worse should we
worry okay I'm on my way okay we're okay
okay okay they're just hammering a
flamethrower those because you do repair
and if I cried I get hit with either gun
no neither gun can do anything okay
there now you fall I'm doing stuff now
boys out it thank you
okay let's do it I can't reach him with
main gun stuff I get it I got him he can
almost almost go and check on him I got
him I got him all I can't hit him mark
is getting him as you can plainly tell
no I keep adding him art no I got it
embedded I can okay he got him Joo young
holy [ __ ] oh you can't buddy I'm sorry
if I just gotten really good yet a lot
of pent-up swim is mine Palace yeah see
these fires aren't coming out of my a
gun they're coming out of my mind you
know that's what I'm fire it's mine fire
you fire
I don't think I thought you were you
download through dumb what am I really
that's good of mind freak hey hey
you